[Music]
I came here with an enthusiasm to make
this the sport in Pakistan
I made a gym people came you know
involve people in online discussions I
promoted different fighters and martial
artist and I made martial arts look cool
while I was deployed in rock I was
reading a biography of Malcolm X he
talked about being adopted by a white
family and kind of feeling like their
pet remember kind of relating to that
and thinking that if I was not wearing
this military uniform what would you be
thinking if I was wearing some Arab
dress so I was kind of the token Muslim
guy on the army uniform
[Music]
the big goal is is to make it the
premier sport in Pakistan possibly
surpassing cricket you know that might
be a big and lofty vision that may or
may not come to fruit but that's the
goal that I see
[Music]